I think I,
I think that philosophy of science is at
its best and edits most exciting at
historical moments when it's not so easy
to distinguish between,
um,
the activities of certain kinds of
theoretical physicists and the
activities of certain kinds of
philosophers.
Um,
um,
philosophy of science,
I think,
or at least.
Well,
let me back up a bit.
There.
There's,
there's philosophy of science can be
divided roughly into two different kinds
of activities.
One is,
um,
one is an activity of raising and
investigating general philosophical
questions about what science is about,
whether the claims of science to have
some kind of privileged epistemic access
to the world can be justified.
Um,
attempts to systematize how science
reasons,
um,
attempts to raise questions about
whether we should trust the conclusions
of science.
So on and so forth.
These are very broad,
very traditionally philosophical kinds
of issues.
There's another branch of philosophy of
science,
um,
that,
takes up questions that arise within
particular scientific theories,
the theory of evolution,
the theory of relativity,
quantum mechanics and so on and so
forth,
and actually gets his hands dirty in the
details of the structure of these
scientific theories in order to try to
help with problems that are often
essentially scientific problems,
but where,
but,
but whose solution calls for an unusual
degree of sensitivity to philosophical
questions.
It's the second kind of work that,
that my own work has mostly been in.
It's the second kind of work that one
refers to when one refers to the
foundations of physics.
There are problems about the logical
structure of physics,
about the foundational assumptions that
physics makes,
whether these problems properly belong
to physics,
are they properly belong to philosophy
when the field is healthy?
Isn't much of an issue.
In my own case,
my phd was in theoretical physics.
Um,
I,
I was a professor in physics departments
before being a professor in philosophy
departments.
Um,
when I write a paper now,
my rule is that if at the end it has
more than two equations in it,
I send it to a physics journal and if it
has less than two,
uh,
I send it to a philosophy journal and
there's not much more of a distinction
than that when I attend conferences.
Um,
um,
where people are discussing the kinds of
questions that I'm interested in,
about half of the people speaking at
these conferences are employed in
physics departments and half are
employed in philosophy departments.
And it's not particularly easy to tell
by listening to their talks what sort of
department they're employed.
And so philosophy of science,
like I say,
when it's healthy,
is a matter of focusing with a certain
level of philosophical sensitivity and
sophistication on questions at the
foundations of physics.